so what are the best practices for
growing on YouTube right now and what's
working when it comes to building a real
Creator business you know it could be
frustrating trying to find answers when
it comes to getting your YouTube channel
views subscribers and figuring out the
back end of how do you monetize how do
you set up brand deals if you have a
small Channel if you're a scaling
Channel and so the reason we created
this show the coffee with candles show
is so that we can do some q a as well as
coaching with individuals looking at
their channels and no matter when you're
watching this you can glean insights
that you can apply real practical advice
for growing on YouTube yourself and so
we're going to dive straight into our
first channel of the day we're going to
be talking to a Bible coach we're also
going to be talking to a news channel
but the nuances that we touch on are
going to be relevant for you and
definitely check out time codes and
chapters because after that we'll be
doing some live q a of just all kinds of
YouTube questions about views
monetization analytics branding personal
branding and all of that kind of stuff
and so buckle your seat belt get ready
because this is the coffee with candle
show
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the coffee with candle
show my name is Sean Cannell rhymes with
YouTube channel today I am sipping on
some Ethiopia coffee from Presta in
Arizona delicious single origin coffee
but we're gonna dive straight into a
conversation with Keith your Bible coach
and I'll be checking out his channel
seeing what we can learn and seeing some
tips that we can all apply Keith welcome
to the show hey great to be here nice to
meet you I'm I think I'm like a 45
minutes south of you I should I should
have made my Mariners hat too
Pacific Northwest what area Kirkland
Kirkland okay awesome well so grateful
you're on here and uh tell us a little
bit about your channel and then your
question today yeah I
I have been an author and speaker for
close to 28 years I was a youth pastor
for six years and through a whole long
series of events just started not just
believing the Bible was true but started
really enjoying it and started
approaching it differently and learning
some different Bible study methods my
background is kind of brain science and
how the brain works and realized that
how we study the Bibles oftentimes
different than how God's wired our
brains to work and so when we marry
those it's better and I started a
YouTube channel back in 2009 and I think
three years later got my first
subscriber because I did absolutely
nothing but post a random video once
every six months and it was really
almost exactly a year ago September 1st
that I just really felt like oh my
goodness
okay I mean we've just met man that's
mean it was 14 years ago oh yeah
um so so it was something that that I
just really it was something that I
heard you say in one of your free
trainings about a year ago where you
said when was the last time that you
watched or you looked at a social media
post that was more than two weeks old
and I thought never and you said when
was the last time you saw a YouTube
video that was five years old and I
thought probably yesterday
and just realized the impact and
Longevity that I could have and so I
made a commitment September 1st of last
year that I would post a video every
single week for two years and then I
would reevaluate but I was making a
two-year commitment and because normally
I commit to things for four to six
months and Men evaluate but I thought
YouTube is a longer tail game than that
so that's incredible online but it's
really teaching people how to read and
study the Bible more than it is just
teaching a Bible passage I love that and
I mean 222 000 views on the channel over
3 300 subscribers and so you've made a
great impact
um already and it's cool to see you
taking the action I think so many
lessons we can learn of just the power
of consistency that power of committing
to once a week
um but is there any specific questions
um we can start off with and I'll give
you some feedback on the channel as well
yeah I think the one of the big
questions that I have is my number one
video well there's an interview I did
where somebody was pretty famous that
that went but it wasn't specific to my
channel but my number one video that I
made is that one that you see the maroon
one
uh the best Bible reading plan for
beginners that one is one that is now
four years old and just last month I
um recorded an updated version for a
playlist that I've created that now has
I think 14 videos released in it called
Bible study for beginners and and so
it's something that I have this video
that's got 22 000 views it keeps getting
more views than anything else but I have
an updated version of it that's much
better
and has some new content and I'm just
wondering what's the best way to point
people to that or is that even important
so that that was that was kind of my
main question because that's the one
that gets traction that's great
um so let's start with just some
practical tips then we'll talk about
some Theory
um around
you know is that replicatable this is a
pain point that a lot of us have but the
first practical tips is if you have a
winner an older video that is
um a winner you know one thing that's
top of mind is sometimes you can help it
win even more like if it ain't broke
don't fix it but what I mean is you
actually can make a small tweak to the
title or even actually update the
thumbnail
um and your best videos can kind of get
even better the principle is like it's
kind of known that the rich get richer
and even biblically sometimes it's like
he who has even more will be given he
who does not have even what he has to be
taken it's sort of like once you already
a video that already has momentum
chances are you can give it more
momentum rather than like a video you're
like that was so good but nobody cares
about it well it might not be possible
to really revive a dead video so
um anyways as I look at it you know you
may have you could have maybe a tighter
headshot or or update the thumbnail a
little bit and then the way you can
actually measure because you can go into
the video to see if it's getting
Impressions right now you make a change
to the title or you make a change to the
thumbnail only do one thing at a time
what you could do is you go to a video
that's winning
so we take like Nolan's video how to
create a YouTube channel for beginners
here we could go to reach
we go to Impressions and we go in the
last seven days any video that is
winning means it's old and getting
Impressions this video is
um came out let's see last published it
came out on January 5th 2021 okay and in
the last seven days it got a quarter
million impressions so it's pretty
that's the power of YouTube so we can
see that it's getting 29 000 Impressions
here a day up to 36 000. so if I was to
take this old video make a change to the
thumbnail and make a change to and then
I would say does this go down to
22 000 Impressions and so if you were
getting 300 Impressions does it go down
to 200 or does it go up to 500 after
giving it a few days if you make one
change either changing the thumbnail or
changing the title okay that's not even
the question you were really asking in
the sense of you're like I want people
to watch the new one but the truth is
sometimes the old one will just continue
to get more and more views and um that
why not have it get even more views
ultimately like in a small tweak to the
thumbnail or to the title could do that
the second tip is
that um exactly what you did I would say
is best practice 2023 update I have
updated and completely redone my answer
to this question here's the new video
and that's above the fold and clickable
so you've already
taken the action to be clear for viewers
watching if you've got an old winning
video
old tutorial or something and there's an
update get a link to that update in the
top three lines of your description so
that it's clickable you also could throw
it on the end card it probably wouldn't
do much but you could throw it on the
end card
one of my favorite things to do on end
cards is don't do the Subscribe button
don't do two videos do just that new
video okay do the one thing that you
want people to do I also think you could
do the
um
you could update the pin comment the
same way you've updated the description
and that might even be stronger so
question of the day what's your favorite
reading plan
um you know a little alert Emoji or
something if I'm on
if I'm on PC which I am I say option
period and it brings up the Emoji and I
can type in Siren so you do a little
siren or something or you could do the
whatever and you you go you know heads
up you know 2023 update with two sirens
on it or the two caution signs or
something like look at this and then I
did an update to it so you could change
this pin comment and remember that if
you edit a pin comment and don't re-pin
it it unpins it doesn't automatically
stay pinned so uh you could update the
pin comment
to the new video now you got the
description now you've got the pin
comment
and those are ultimately kind of your
your best practice I think with your new
video that's out you you could add extra
juice to it by posting on the community
tab
um to it there could be a lot better use
on the community tab in general here but
you could do it one of two ways you link
to the video it's my least favorite way
you link to a square image is the best
way and so if there's a square version
of your
thumbnail because the community tab
operates in square images not rectangle
images so this is a square version of my
interview with Jade Dharma wongsa and
this is a square version of my interview
with
um John ushai and I'm actually
cross-promoting channels here this is
think media letting people know about a
think media podcast episode but that's
sort of separate but I think what the
punch line I'm getting at is you're
trying to
get juice going views going awareness
going to this new video because you want
the new video to outrank the old video
but the final thing to know is
this is a common pain point for creators
ourselves included you know if you've
been doing it as long as you have four
years ago you were creating content
three four years ago 2020 March 2020
different Creator Journeys
the people got hundreds of thousands of
views and now they're getting 10 000
views they don't know why well everybody
was locked down people were consuming
more content right so the the
circumstances around when it originally
came out four years ago there was less
competition around beginner Bible
reading plans
still it's possible to break out today
but that's why we're here talking to
pursue Mastery for thumbnails titles
content creation
um understanding YouTube but it's a
different world so you're getting 22 000
views there's a lot of external factors
that we don't need to overthink but I
can just relate with you and relate with
our community
when Omar and I and Nolan talk a lot
about remaking our old videos because
there is an update there's an update to
best YouTube Studio or best YouTube
Studio under
um a thousand dollars and our four years
ago version has 555 000 views and our
new one has 55 000 views and it's better
it's more current it's a better answer
the technology is better
but sometimes it just kind of is what it
is and those the content hasn't had time
to age so your most recent video
give it 40 years right if you've done
good promotional tactics it's a good
video The Hook is good and some of those
sometimes it's it's hard to recreate
magic you know because and it's not even
that it was magic but there's just
something about the new the new version
what you could do on a practical level
is you could compare both of their
audience retention curves next to each
other to also see maybe for some reason
this one has a better audience retention
curve do you know how to do that
uh yeah I think I think so yeah with I'm
within the analytics on that particular
video right yeah so to get an audience
retention curve the video needs to be
um a little bit
older I'm gonna look for a video that
okay there's a good nine minute one
Nolan did and so yeah what you could do
is is study the audience retention curve
what's the average view iteration what's
the average percentage viewed what are
some Peaks or valleys around here are
they related to time codes and chapters
which they are here how does it perform
and then compare those two things
because
if we're not looking at those minutes
consumed aspect
no matter how good you do on the title
or the thumbnail or share it on the
community tab
the net net result of viewers
consumption is one video holds the
attention better than than the others
and so
the last tactic would in fact be
that your most recent version with
attempt to update it is maybe better
information it's more current
but it doesn't perform as well
in terms of average audience retention
you should make it again
three months from now six months from
now more occurrent again with those new
insights we're a big believer here at
think media there's different
philosophies
that it's okay to repeat yourself and we
should be a lot of times saying the same
things in new ways to new people
sometimes people say always say new
things I think that's ridiculous
especially like in theology you don't
want to always be saying new things
that's dangerous but what you want to do
is you want to say the same things like
of course these are truths but you're
looking for new ways and what does new
ways mean new ways new ways of packaging
it a new angle on the title a new look
on the thumbnail a new structure in the
hook a new presentation of the material
that maybe includes storytelling the new
implementation of open Loops curiosity
Loops or different things in the way the
video is structured and so
I also take responsibility that maybe
the video we originally made on like
let's say a best studio under a thousand
dollars for YouTube
it it just has a good audience retention
I maybe didn't even do it fully
intentionally but I gave my best and the
new one for some reason loses engagement
with the audience well still if one guy
500 000 views for us and one got 55 000
well both that's still a win and then
let's try it again and and
it's it's we will want to continue to
talk about there's maybe a new tweak to
it because a new version of the road
might came out it's even a better price
so the new video has something new to it
but don't be afraid to remake some of
your winning Concepts continually
educated people how to do a beginning a
Beginner's Bible reading plan or
something like that
um in a fresh way it's about to be
dependent 2024 at the time of us
recording this so a lot of the best
topics are your most consistent topics
on your channel and this goes for
everybody in our think media podcast and
coffee with candle Community I love New
Years because it really is a new
opportunity to remake almost every
single one of your videos meaning
tips for you know starting a Bible
reading plan in 2024. that is a getting
that out in January is a big deal like
this is these are the nuances that help
people really get an edge on YouTube
because of timing and understand sort of
seasons and then it's a new year maybe
the years included in the title maybe it
isn't uh maybe there's a new version of
the Christian Standard Bible translation
or something that you can jump on like
just different things I I love the new
year but but saying that those are quite
a few thoughts about you know what to do
with your top video and recreating your
top video any follow-up questions as we
land the plane
yeah no I I mean that's
that's super super helpful as far as
just you know the re-pinning the comment
the pinned comment some of those
different different tips for for sure
right yeah it's just one of those things
pointing people to new content the idea
of they can both be a win that's that's
something I just kind of need to
remember and think through and do you
would you then I guess the follow-up
question to that is let's say that the I
I redo that and the older one still
continues to perform better and I'm
getting more views on that do you then
change the description within it to
reference some newer things that as far
as the monetization of it just
completely update the description of it
yeah so to just to address maybe the
emotions you're feeling as I get it you
kind of unless the old video is
officially heresy now and you actually
realize that like I don't know it's not
bad I literally don't want it public
anymore what's frustrating to us as
creators is we we know oh it's not even
my best answer like and on the one hand
it's oh it's not even my new studio but
but I think we get too emotionally
involved your ability to get this to 44
000 views might be easier than even you
getting some of your new videos there is
I mean you want to do both but yeah but
we we we dishonor the past in that way
so saying that not only linking to the
new version yeah the the even perhaps
bigger strategy could be this if people
can get your uh opt-in here I'm assuming
it might be better rather than even
sending them somewhere else let this
video do its thing people still like it
they're still getting value Lee to have
it lead to building your email list as
you're doing and then you know
descriptions are always worth optimizing
but we should never be delusional to
think that everyone's going there and
reading every line but we actually just
had a big discussion uh at think media
here today
um about
the fact that we have like talk with
think.com literally in our default
description literally in this coffee
with candle right now which is not even
a thing right now in the default
description here is not accurate and as
Drea is listening in the background and
Kyle they're hearing that because they
weren't even there for this conversation
so we're trying to stay current and over
on think media it's accurate but it's
not here and so
um that's kind of we we use the term
spring cleaning I think there's always
spring cleaning opportunities to
optimizing some of our previous best
videos to updating links uh things on
our website things that no longer exist
because on a macro and you never know
when you're going to go viral you put
out a video it blows up while you're
taking a two-week sabbatical and
somebody and one person all it needs to
be is one but like 2 000 views 20 people
are like how can I learn more about what
you're doing and they go to your
description you want them to be able to
clearly find the different aspects of
your your business your ministry your
creator business so it's absolutely
worth taking some time to optimize you
know some of those previous things you
could potentially optimize it probably
Auto did these chapters I don't know if
you did those that's something YouTube
will do on its own so that's another way
to optimize old videos is time codes and
chapters it
that's a debate people have because
sometimes they think it lessens audience
retention which is certainly an argument
it also could increase the value for the
viewer
um
and so thinking about all the above is
something you could do and actually I
want to shout out our sponsor today and
even
um it's vid IQ you can check out
vidiq.com forward slash think to get a
30-day trial of vidiq's boost plan
something that I thought we could
actually do that'd be interesting is one
it's if you were to split test this
title okay again number one you know
audit how many Impressions the video got
in like the last seven days maybe it's a
hundred maybe it's a thousand
Impressions is not views but Impressions
is YouTube suggesting it or it's showing
up in search all these different things
and you split test one thing even if you
didn't change the thumbnail you know
using vid IQ one of the things that's
interesting is this says um your title
is the best Bible reading plan for
beginners I'm going to say get title
ideas
and
um unlocking the secrets of the best
Bible reading plan break free from
beginner status discover the Bible
reading plan expert swear by the Bible
reading plan every beginner should know
about transform your spiritual journey
with the perfect Bible reading plan
um I'm not in love with any of these but
they really help me get thinking and so
this is vid iq's AI title recommendation
tool I just thought we could kind of
play with this around your channel you
also have the AI coach here and you
could say right
uh a better title
for this topic
and the best Bible reading plan for
beginners one of the really cool things
about vid IQ
um and they did this for us recently now
okay this is going to kind of mess with
you because it's based on my channel so
it's saying based on the data uh think
media it we recently did this and not
only people say well why good IQ versus
chat gbt I can just use chat GPT for for
free well that's a good point you should
use chat GPT everybody should it's very
helpful tool
um but the unique thing about vid IQ is
they are actually tapping into that API
but they're able to almost make it an AI
assistant that thinks in YouTube the way
that YouTube thinks and that looks at
your actual channel so recently we used
it for some title brainstorming and it
gave us a paragraph of
um
of explanation of what was better about
the title why the title was clearer and
we ended up implementing the title and
getting a higher performance on a video
but I really like these easy to follow
Bible reading guide for newbies
um Beginner's Bible reading plan leading
with that potentially Beginner's Bible
reading plan colon so sometimes I don't
necessarily use the title
exactly as they state it I go ooh
Beginner's Bible reading plan that
really is nice now what is yours the
best Bible reading plan for beginners
um the best beginners like where
beginner is what is what what are people
looking for mastering the Bible a
comprehensive guide for beginners so
anyways one thing you could do is come
up with a new title
using a tool and if you want to check
this out coffee with Canal Community
vidiq.com forward slash think shout out
um not just a sponsor but a tool that we
are actively using um on all of our
channels now you can get a 30-day trial
of the Boost plan tap into that AI coach
title coach and all that other stuff
you could come up with a new title
paste it in there
save it and then look at your
impressions 24 46
um 48 72 hours later and see if your
impressions go up and then you can pivot
your thumbnail and see if your
impressions go up and I know
they're older videos you're like well I
want to work on the new thing but
imagine if we even get a small increase
in our click-through rate and that video
that is four years old keeps getting
views for the next four years at a one
percent increase or two percent or five
percent
this starts to get my mind excited as a
Creator I go oh my gosh exponentially
over time small tweaks and optimizing my
content and so does that make sense oh
totally totally super super helpful
awesome any final question Keith as we
land the plane today uh yeah I I've got
a question on on consistency because so
I've got two different areas that I'm
exploring when it comes to so I've got
my consistent video that comes out every
Tuesday and has for a year and committed
to doing that I've been considering
doing a live quite honestly very similar
to this where I do live questions that
people ask that might not warrant a full
15 to 20 minute explanatory video just
and having kind of a live coffee chat
my because of my own travel schedule for
speaking at events and different things
there isn't a consistent in time when I
have a recorded video that I can
schedule to be out it can be very
consistent at the same time every
Tuesday a live one I could do a couple
times a month but I don't know that I
can always do that so I have a question
about that and then a consistency
question when it comes to shorts if
um if if it's okay yeah so question
number one I think in an ideal world you
would do a live show that's every
Tuesday at 7 A.M Pacific Standard Time
and and people could count on it
because the power of consistency too is
if people if it could be same time same
place you can even tap into traditional
media however we're not in a perfect
world and you and me and everybody
watching this whether it's their travel
schedule whether it's having a one and
three-year-old and before a certain time
of day you couldn't even be standing in
my office like I am because every
morning I'm with like it's always
different circumstances I think the next
best thing is to just do it this show is
a great example of that the coffee with
candle show is not at a consistent time
it is at a consistent place here on the
think video podcast channel it's not
even consistent every single week but it
is consistent meaning it started back in
2020 and here we are today and the the
fruit of it is is wild not only in how
we create the show but how things are
repurposed out of it so my encouragement
to you is
start before you're ready done is better
than perfect and my encouragement to
everybody watching this is don't
overthink because you can't do it
perfect according to
what your personality might require like
if it isn't every if I can't commit to
this for the next if if not only can I
not do this show every week at the same
time at the same place but I don't even
know if my son is ready to be my
successor and if he can't carry it on
for 10 generation and the show ends then
why even do the show at all you know
that's sometimes where we go though it's
like
or just go live like when you can and
answer questions you know that's the
other more relaxed approach like do it
one time take six months off and do it
again like in the punch line if 22
people are there live watching and the
replay value so
and then your season might change
because right now we're continuing to up
coffee with candle I just said I want to
do it four times a month
some weeks I know we won't be able to
but I want to prioritize this thing and
uh that was my stated goal when I was
just working
um with uh Jordan my EA and so whatever
you know I hope that helps and then
we'll end we'll end with shorts what's
your question on shorts so my question
on shorts is my kind of Rhythm for that
has been that
when I'm out walking my dog in the
morning probably four to five times a
week I will just pull up and I record it
typically with Instagram I'll record
something under 60 Seconds
I'll turn on the captions I'll post it
to Instagram I have it set to
automatically download and right now I
open up YouTube and I upload the video
and have the same kind of caption over
and it's just a thought that I have for
the day and it's just casual walking
near my house in Kirkland and sometimes
my dog is in it and it's just something
just a thought for the day and my
question is
is is that Rhythm good is there some way
specifically the difference between what
you see on Instagram and the difference
between what you see on YouTube
is there something that I should do
before posting it to YouTube to make it
different not for the sake of being
different but because oh you want to add
this kind of hashtag or you want to tag
this here or you want to change these
kind of captions don't do well is there
something
that is different about the way that
YouTube likes shorts versus Instagram
likes reels that I should change before
uploading it to YouTube
well the first thing I want to
acknowledge that is
something everyone should pay attention
to is the workflow you've created here I
think the fact that you've created a
rhythm and a repeatable system
essentially is amazing and I think the
consistency
because the fact you go 2 000 views 167
views and you go 5 300 views
on a couple 2500 views this is I think
proof that 99 of people watching this
are overthinking and that they have a
walk with the dog they have
um a time of their day where they could
create a particular format so I'm
actually in love with that I would much
rather you could you keep doing
something that's consistent
um then
again lock yourself in a room hoping to
make the one short to rule them all like
the Lord of the Rings
and ultimately hesitate forever because
out of your consistency is a lot of good
things already happening I think the
other thing we always need to audit is
even our sword strategy is also a
consistent pattern it's mainly just
repurposed from the podcast
how do I know if my shorts strategy is
being consist uh successful always look
at the math go to cons go to analytics
go to content don't click all don't
click videos click shorts and see what
it says here and if you are positive
subscribers if you're getting likes if
you're getting shown in the feed if
you're getting views and you look across
what's happening
if it's up then great and there's all
kinds of debates about shorts first long
form but when I when I look at the math
I go okay our short strategy is worth
doing
then tip two which is a really great
question you're asking is once you've
created I think this isn't
it's such a big takeaway
for everybody watching this like
figure out something you can do
sustainably that's why we love video
podcasting it's like if you can do a
podcast once a week then do it well is
it the best who cares if it's the best
you can sustain it you're busy you could
shoot four interviews all in one day a
month maybe and then put one up a month
like create a system if you can go on a
walk and share the thought of the day
consistently then
you now have something that you can
foundationally build on on YouTube but
then here's my advice Keith
then
think about within the
constraints of this daily walk the dog
show how you could improve this
and
we've probably both heard Craig Rochelle
say like creativity works best in
constraints essentially
would other shorts perform better well
probably but like this is the
environment with which you're going to
um be working with which is good because
we just created some constraints okay
it's when I walk it's in the morning
okay great so now how could we improve
this show well you're already you've
been studied communication you've been a
great communicator for a long time but I
would continue to think about really
studying hooks really studying the Open
Line really studying that kind of stuff
maybe thinking about experimenting with
topics because this is coming from your
heart it's probably coming from your
prayer time your Bible time but perhaps
one morning you start making connections
or even pray about this like holy spirit
I pray for insights of how to tie the
Bible as I'm studying it to things that
are happening in culture because you're
talking heads short titled
um you know responding to maybe
something that's related to Trend
surfing or influence surfing not because
it's a tactic but because you actually
feel it and you see biblical truth
applied to what's happening in culture
boom now you got a viral short from the
dog walk 555
000 views
because in the constraints there's a lot
of different ways you could take it
maybe you start playing with angles and
you realize that if you set your phone
down you could actually do like a hook
in an opening
then you could do like the content in
the middle and then you could do a
selfie on the call to action out and
exactly I know you're keeping it very
simple but you're outside anyways you're
getting fresh air anyways I don't know
if you have to like walk the whole time
you used to start realizing like while
you're outside you start experimenting
with cinematography and angles this is
something I personally am good at
because I've just been creating video
for so long I can Assemble
if you will I'll put the the video of
the camera
in a tree I'll be as I'm walking I'm
looking for something where the phone
can set up and I'll I'll walk up to it
and then I'll hit record walk away from
it walk back up to it and when I put on
my phone you just trim the front and
then it's just you walking so
have you ever wondered what Jesus meant
when he said whatever and maybe you just
start experimenting with the hooks a
little bit different and then the rest
is you walking and it's still it's kind
of in the same amount of time but you
can see how there's so much we could do
to this one show by now thinking about
improving the show and then I think that
cap cut could be really interesting
um it's so easy to use I pay for the uh
the pro version of cap cut but there are
I think I think the way you're doing it
is fine but you're asking how can we
improve the show I think this style of
captions is pretty rad it's one word at
a time and uh goes fast it's kind of a
viewer retention hack it's one of the
things for the uh the captions that and
cap cut and the pro version gives you
all kinds of different ones so again
you're out
you learn you're adding to your tool
belt keep it in Instagram for a year I
don't care but I'm just saying there
could be uh you throw it in cap cut
learn a little bit of editing add that
to your routine and now there it's just
a different hack for retention or it
relates more to the content and so
um
or or something like that might not
relate as much to the content but that's
kind of that faster Pace YouTube shorts
Vibe and then like another thought is as
you put it into YouTube yes you can
select the thumbnail that's just a
thought it's probably going to be pretty
consistent the way it looks here but you
you hit it before you post it and you
slide your finger through
and your knowledge of that might I'm
starting to think about props as well
like maybe maybe your episode where
you're like you know
I was walking and like this this tree is
dead and you you like your first scene
is whatever because you can actually
upload a thumbnail you just select the
thumbnail and um
and then music I do think it's
interesting that you can you upload this
and then before you on on YouTube
there's music that's allowed to be used
you could use some trending music
obviously you're not going to use like
something sketchy or whatever but you
might even use you know Gyra Lo-Fi from
like worship mob and it kind of ties in
you've turned it down to 10 percent and
then that allows there to be a little
bit of music which can increase
retention ties into like your brand or
your Vibe so there's like four or five
or six ideas of literally what you could
just do to this show
um and all of that might have seemed a
little bit overwhelming uh like a fire
hose from my perspective like wow it's
like a learning curve but I think this
the goal here is to encourage all of us
I love the fact that you've got
creativity that can work within
constraints and if you just sharpen this
skill
I and then you multiply that by the
repetition
you'll be speaking at a conference in a
year and someone will be like man how
did your like daily walk show start
getting 33 000 videos on average an
episode you're like well eventually what
I kind of figured out was I did like a
powerful opening line and I started to
kind of edit it together this way but
yeah I only ever did it on my phone and
it took me a while I eventually learned
cap cut and there's a certain kind of
song and I started to think about the
Rhythm and I looked at the ones that
performed best and what topics those
were and I noticed that this particular
caption even personally I put myself in
the the shoes of the viewer and and like
this caption
um format was my favorite one in cap cut
and um all of the above you know I think
could could improve it any is that
helpful at all oh super super helpful
super helpful yeah I I love it I don't
I don't know if we have time I I'd love
to get your kind of first impression
feedback of the layout of the YouTube
channel itself like is there something
that when you glance at the homepage of
the YouTube channel do you just go
oh this is great or this header really
sucks it doesn't tell us anything or you
know great great question four times
sake I want to make sure we get to Steve
and the Q a on today's show we've
already covered a ton and so yeah I
appreciate it so much man I appreciate
you Keith and uh thank you so much for
coming on the coffee with Channel show
today but I also uh yeah I hope we could
connect more in the future and love what
you're doing and how you're impacted
people and changing the world well thank
you so much and I've appreciated being
in VRA you guys what you do uh is um is
fantastic quality wise and the integrity
and authenticity with which you do it
um you are also changing the world so
appreciate you many blessings brother
thank you Keith all right
all right coffee with candle that was uh
that was a fun master class I think
Steph like clipping that would be
interesting
um I I
want to ask you your aha moment so far
as we get ready for Steve
um and think about what action you can
Implement I am super inspired by what
Keith was doing because
he's gonna go on a walk every day he's
got a routine he's got also a routine of
being filled up I think that's I'm I'm
making this assumption about Keith's
life but as creatives we pour out a lot
we I think we need to make sure that
we're being poured into if you always
want to have fresh creativity like hey
man how do I keep coming up with ideas
and having messages now as a person of
faith that can look like prayer and
meditation on the Bible and scripture
reading
um and and absorbing that but also just
in the crater economy in general I do
think having a diet where this is the
fun part of consumption not just
consuming mindless entertainment but
consuming things that that iron sharpens
iron so whether that's an online course
whether that's uh a powerful Book
audiobook I have found that going on a
walk listening to an audiobook as a
parent and busy parents I've got a
three-year-old and a one-year-old
throwing some air pods I'm listening to
this book called trust by Henry Cloud Dr
Henry cloud
going on a walk I'm taking my kids to
the Jungle Gym pushing them around the
neighborhood in this dual stroller that
we got and it's like giving me all these
ideas it's it's about trust it's applied
to my marriage I'm thinking about how
trust is Flowing on our think media team
but I also realized that his five points
for trust is exactly relevant to YouTube
content creators that first people want
to be understood they then want to know
what your motive is is your motive for
their good or they've sent it for
themselves they then want to know do you
have the ability to help me that's you
having the ability to build your
credibility you maybe see a silver play
button go play button you're like okay
well at least this guy can you know
hopefully hopefully help me that's the
credibility piece then you've got the uh
the next one and then the final one is
track record have they done this again
and have they done this uh repeatedly
character is the next one and not just
honesty and integrity those are paid
number four is honesty and integrity and
character those are permission to play
attributes but character also like
they're not going to lash out or they
don't you know just because you're
honest doesn't mean you have the right
character to help me get to my result
and then track record what's your
history and helping people or doing what
you do here's my point the five things
in Dr Henry Cloud's book we'll link this
up uh if you want to check it out
audiobook or physical book in the
description are like five Essentials for
business Creator economy YouTube
creators you need if you want to
actually build trust build a community
you ultimately have to first start with
understanding what's your motive do you
have the ability to help me do you have
the character and do you have the track
record and if you have all five of those
things well then look at the results in
terms of subscribers or people buying
into what you're doing or people wanting
to buy your product or support you
everything moves at the speed of trust
so anyways that was some uh content that
came from me consuming and now I'm able
to deliver it here on coffee with candle
so I want to encourage you of course
you're here sharpening the ax if you
will sharpening the SOB I hear uh being
here and be and learning
um and as you continue to do that
that'll help you make even better videos
the AHA creating uh videos
um on ideas of old videos it's really
great I think characters when you who
you are when no one else is looking yep
that's really good
um appreciate you Jerry Cherry Band
thank you so much for the comments and
uh really good stuff with Keith
appreciate you Keith thanks so much for
being here up next is Steve and we're
gonna go to Steve in just one second
after this short break if you've been a
part of the think media Community for a
while and you're ready to take your
video marketing game to the next level
then you're gonna love
21videotips.com for a limited time you
can get access to our free video master
class with the top 21 video marketing
secrets from creators and business
owners like Alex hermosi Patrick Bet
David Jasmine star Vanessa Lau Pat Flynn
chalene Johnson and more of the greatest
marketing Minds in our industry get
Advanced tactics for free in this no
fluff video Master Class by clicking the
link in the description or just heading
to to 21videotips.com
welcome back to the coffee with candle
show my name is Sean Cannell where we
are taking your YouTube questions all
about the business side of YouTube
making money growing your channel I
definitely encourage you if you're
jumping on live
check out the replay
um and check out check out time codes
and chapters
um because that first conversation had a
lot of tactical fire in it on this next
conversation we're going to be looking
at a news channel and I am super excited
to welcome
the polar report to the show today Steve
how's it going
hey so great to be with you here this is
uh this is super exciting for me um and
like you just said uh first uh 40
minutes or so it's just jam-packed I was
like taking notes all over the place uh
so much wisdom you're just tossing out
uh all over the place man I appreciate
your kind words and uh I'm so excited
for to have you on the show you are the
host of the pull the Poplar report uh
break it down when did you get into
YouTube what are you doing on YouTube
and what is it you're up to yeah so uh
two years and one month ago I started
posting every day I was like I'm gonna
give this a swing I've been listening to
you guys uh on think media for a year
year and a half before that just
researching researching researching
researching and and finally I was like
you know what I just I gotta go into
this and uh and it's been a wild ride
the last two years uh I'm now doing this
full time and it's uh it's crazy got a
major uh backing of some really loyal
little followers and listeners and it is
simple stuff that I'm doing on this
channel and that's that's the the word
is that it's talking head unedited
videos and yet uh we're getting over
three million views long form views
exclusively a month and it's uh it's
it's awesome starting trying to build a
team here and uh that's that's a whole
new set of challenges here but um
um I know that it's a season that a lot
of people really are looking forward to
getting into being able to be full-time
being able to bring on some of your
friends uh some new friends uh to your
staff and um
overwhelmed and and that's going to be
leading into the question actually
yeah first thing I want to make a note
of is also what an inspiring story so
another story we we of course talked to
Michael Zuber from one rental at a time
he doesn't do any editing I think you
just blew people's minds you're you're
getting 3.4 million views a month no
editing but I do want to ask one
question just that I would assume as an
observer I I think that no editing
doesn't mean a reduction in the quality
of the content especially related and
here's my guess and correct me if I'm
wrong you spend a lot of time
researching you deeply care about your
information the things that you're
looking up maybe structure of the videos
do you just go off the cuff or are you
going off of an outline of some research
and some different things what goes into
maybe creating one of your videos on
these various topics
yeah absolutely tons of research and
when we say quality of content we don't
necessarily mean Quality quality of
editing and Transitions and Sparkle
graphics and all that kind of stuff like
that but when we're talking about the
the amount of research and knowledge of
the subject is is so critical so yeah
three four hours of research uh per
videos is not unreasonable and not
unheard of
um I live and breathe this Channel and
uh uh I'm single so I can I can pull
that off but if I was married uh I'd
probably be divorced by now I think or
else we would have had a very tough
conversation I think about uh needing to
pull back and get some balance in life
but uh like I said I'm in a season of
life where uh Ministry and then this uh
is my life I really connected with Keith
that's why scribbling notes like crazy
is because uh I have a side Channel
that's actually just straight Bible
study and so I I promote that from this
channel I don't really get into bible
study on this channel and welcome
but yeah so I do a verse by verse Bible
study over there and uh we post those
weekdays and stuff like that so um you
know it's uh same kind of thing it's
just we just have a Bible study together
and it's not really made to kind of blow
up morning it's a passion project and
it's you know it's for people that like
me and are connected to me as a person
uh going over there and getting their
Bible study so it's like 6 a.m every
morning I post my Bible video and then 6
15 a.m comes out my first video on my
main Channel but that means that on
weekdays I'm basically posting three
long-form videos a day which is uh crazy
yeah and respect uh another of course
big takeaway is
you're doing the work you are putting in
the work whether that's the
um research whether that's the
commitment to the schedule I would guess
whether you feel like doing it or not
you you've committed to something so you
continue to show up and that consistency
is paying off
um but uh I also and and it's it's also
producing dividends but would it be
accurate Steve to say
you're also fueled by Passion that one
of the reasons why you're able to put in
that work is because
you wake up with a fire to research
these topics to to share the message
you're sharing you wake up with a
passion for the word and for God's word
and so that is what fuels you to keep
doing this
yeah I'm I've always been a News Junkie
ever since like high school it's like I
couldn't get enough news always reading
the news and that was kind of what led
into this channel I started a Bible
Channel
um the Bible channel was first and it
didn't really go anywhere and that was
fine
um you know just try and be faithful
there and then uh I was like you know
maybe I'll start a channel that can just
talk about the news a little bit and I
saw some channels kind of doing that
kind of thing and they're pretty
successful uh with without editing and I
was like I can do what they're doing I
can just use a really you know a half
decent mic and actually put some
lighting up and uh and that will give me
a Competitive Edge over them so I was
like I'll jump into that and those
people that kind of pattern the channel
after and kind of you know pick like
three or four channels that I was kind
of drawing from inspiration from and
then just add on a higher quality video
higher quality lighting higher quality
audio and just like uh that that's the
competitive advantage that I went after
and I got kind of Lucky my Niche is
blowing up uh it's just real pivot
people are moving away from mainstream
media and they're moving into wanting to
have more authenticity and kind of being
able to package the the kind of talk
radio type feel the podcast feel it
feels authentic it feels kind of edgy
because it's live kind of feel you know
you never know what's going to happen I
don't edit out my oopsies I either just
restart the video or
um you know I kind of let some stuff in
there you know and I think that people
just really kind of appreciate that
authenticity it's not overproduced it's
not
um you know sent out to a poll of people
to kind of you know decide uh whether
they like this wording or that wording
it's it's just it's who I am and uh I
nerd out on the news and so it flows
from the passion if I wasn't passionate
about reading news if I wasn't just
doing that my off time anyway
um this would be completely
unsustainable that's for sure man what
do you do when you're off time anyway
that's uh something that I think about
personally as well where one of the one
of the things for me is including
I do podcasts about books I did a whole
series on the fake media podcast about
uh marketing Warfare about the book
positioning today I'm breaking down
trust it's it's also that's my passion I
do think as a leader I think it's
important
um I'm the CEO founder of fake media so
I am trying to think about it in that
context but I genuinely genuinely also
love to learn about a particular thing
too I find you know I want to get
excited about history but I I usually
gravitate towards a leadership book or a
business book maybe business history I'm
trying to I'm getting a little bit into
Finance but that's my big key if I State
I love marketing so I want to distill
the best video marketing principles the
best YouTube marketing principles I I'm
sharing all this because I want to
encourage our viewers and listeners man
when you get a line with your passion
because you wouldn't want to do this as
a tactic the tactic is mainstream media
is on the way down and Independent Media
is on the way up there's lots of
different Trends you could jump onto
it's also wild that was no editing look
at 622 000 views 412 000 views and then
thinking about the ad revenue and all
the perks and benefits but if you took
the passion piece out man it'd be
unsustainable Michael Zuber from one
rental at a time he does the daily
financial news before he ever started
YouTube he'd get up and study the
markets and articles and financial
articles for 60 to 90 minutes how can
you take what you already are curious
about what you already study what you
already love what you already invest
your money into and essentially monetize
it
and that passion also becomes a
necessary fuel through for putting in
the amount of work and almost escape
velocity needed to break through on
YouTube but let's get to your question
it's been really awesome to hear your
story Steve and I know there's a lot of
nuggets in your story that we can all
learn from but uh what's one of your
questions today
so I'm a full-time Trend surfing
YouTuber right
um I I don't do the search based content
so much
um it's it's about putting out those
videos every day I put two long form
videos every day on my channel and
actually they kind of burn out within
the first 12 to 24 hours it's uh it's
crazy
um so a lot of the videos kind of die a
hard death after after 24 hours I'm
getting hardly any views on them but
they get a lot of views front end my
community kind of jumps on those videos
and they watch them but uh once they
kind of go so it's it's kind of this
challenge that I've I've started on the
hamster wheel and
it's great but on the on the flip side
of that uh the season of sacrifice has
been here but how do you get off the
hamster wheel I mean that's kind of
really where I'm at is uh that because I
don't have search based content so much
and if I do have stuff that's useful for
search it's it's getting buried under an
avalanche of trend surfing videos and
YouTube doesn't know who what videos to
kind of push out to people and so it's
kind of like what options do I have at
kind of getting some work life balance
back and uh stepping out of the season
of sacrifice without it just hammering
the business
yeah it's a great question so
um this will be a fun fun conversation I
think
there's two
huge questions that will help you and
anybody else that's in this situation
the first question is how can I optimize
the current thing
that is my bread and butter and
producing the money and the results
how can I buy back my time and keep
doing that thing
so
it's an incredible blessing that you
have built yourself into
um
full-time that you're you've got these
views you've got the money coming in now
to make this sustainable like you said
building a team that's where we're going
to be going with this
but also the the same bless this is true
for all entrepreneurs startups sometimes
the very thing it's almost like the
answer to the prayer that we were
praying for sometimes all of a sudden
now that it's here we're like yeah this
is also kind of heavy though because now
it's like okay I am full-time money is
coming in but I'm gonna die you know
it's like the next like and so that's
wow I didn't realize now this is gonna
be hard to be hard to sustain especially
depending on how you're building
but the mistake you could make I don't
think you're going to the mistake you
could make is once something gets
working in a Creator business
the biggest mistake anybody could make
is starting to ignore or dishonor or get
distracted from that main thing working
so even though you are as you said
self-described and that's accurate a
trend surfing Channel
it's an incredible you figure out you
crack the code you have a model that
works
that is step one in business and I feel
it yeah if I Veer off of it's it's that
channel the rut that I'm in um is is a
blessing but it does feel like a curse
every time I try to get my wheels a
little bit off to the side I feel the
pushback on The View counts dropping and
stuff like that and just forces me back
into that channel it's like the same
topics same type of videos I need to
kind of keep doing in order to keep the
machine running
so so question number one is you found
the thing that's working
how do I optimize and buy back my time
for the thing that is working because
what's also going to be hard is for you
now to build a new thing you've got to
get your time back so this is like an
entrepreneurial dilemma it's a YouTube
Creator dilemma you get onto the hamster
wheel it's a blessing to be there
because you're full-time
but your exit to the hamster wheel at
some point you can't just be adding more
hours and adding more grit and adding
more because then that really can put
you to burn out
but you also don't want to like let the
current thing you are doing Drop
so
my thought exactly one how could I hire
a team and buy back my time to get more
sanity
how could I now that money's coming in
how much money is coming in
what kind of margins do I have and how
could I spend that money
on buying back my time and some of the
out of the box things so you might think
well
one could be to hire a researcher maybe
somebody helps you cut down your
research time
um two
it could be to hire a house cleaner to
definitely stop doing anything in your
life anything that's delegatable
because even though you might I could
just do it myself you know I create my
Bible study video I create my two news
videos I research for five six seven
eight hours and then so it could be um
you know hello fresh it could be like it
could be where Dave Ramsey's like
you're ordering Uber Eats too much for
the successful entrepreneur that's
scaling you're not ordering ubereats
enough
that's a big unlock like my wife and I
we're small town kids and sometimes
there's certain expenditures that like
the old us
like coming from that world of not
enough or coming from the world of well
we could just save time
sure
but now there's times when I'm wondering
like I'm paying a nanny to watch the
kids so my wife and I can take a nap
and I'm like man uh seems I'm not even
actually being productive no I am being
productive because rest that allows me
to stay healthy
um allows me to continue to do what I'm
doing that's producing and then it
becomes uh
kind of an Arbitrage question of like
you you could you should do a
calculation of how much is your time
worth
because how much time do you put in in a
month figure out well based on the money
coming in my time's worth 25 35 55 66
dollars if I if I calculate everything
else I do a month so now if I could hire
somebody for 15 hours to buy me back an
hour or two
uh here and even just get more sleep
stay more healthy and then because we're
trying to get time for the next thing
too to build some of this I have tips
for that but that's how could I buy back
my time and not only that how could I
also invest money in just scaling
even if it is somebody super basic
upwork.com
they do these thumbnails for you the the
pushback is you're like this is uh it
takes me six minutes like I changed the
text no yeah but what you want to start
doing is installing systems at every
point of your business that you can that
help it go faster that help it scale
more and even a thought of before we
start looking for like let's say search
based content that could get you away
from the content a little bit
um from the trend stuff
um or just create more than enough so
you could actually have a break
how could you actually even double your
views and your Revenue now
without
um
doubling your effort because you are
what you have the Big Mo you have
momentum and one of the most powerful
things to have is momentum you actually
increasing your views 25
50 percent
is a few small tweaks away and maybe how
do I improve the show is is there I
still am live but could I have a remote
person could there be music that comes
in could they actually support me in
some way could I use stream yard in such
a way where I bring in some other things
well I don't have time to put some stuff
in slides and visuals but actually if
somebody else built that for me and and
thus if you were to hire a cleaner or
some way to get some extra sleep even
the time of then hiring these people is
stressful
yeah that's that's what I run into is
that uh I I tried hiring people but then
I found that my management of them and
my training of them was more work than
just doing it myself and uh I know some
of it's like you want to get into that
so what my recent thing is
um I'm working on hiring a competent
manager uh bringing a competent manager
on full-time and I've been just telling
them like you're in charge of everything
like I'm just shoving everything under
you I don't even wanna I don't want to
talk to these people like they're great
people
um but I'm gonna want you to kind of
manage these things and I want to manage
them through you so that I don't have to
take I'm not managing 10 different
people trying to do stuff
yeah and so that's great I think you
also are presenting the number one
needed role for 99 of creators
it's it's the integrator role it's the
manager role your your Genius zone is
researching spotting the news spotting
the trend figuring out the angle of the
video so you're essentially looking for
operations and someone to take off that
other side of the brain that kind of
stresses you out I do want to challenge
just one mindset you have though
on the I completely agree and empathize
with what you're saying I like I don't
even want to manage them or I don't even
want to think about them I just want to
challenge that a little bit to say
for you to go to the next level though
and what you're building
you do got to keep growing as a leader
and grow and as a leader
I think and I'm even saying this was
your tone but I but I think that your
mindset towards them should be different
it's more like
I we have a mission
I have weaknesses
I know that I'm not good at management
even the buy-in for this person and I
need you to help me build that and I
also I'm seeing the opportunity of these
people who we all really deeply care
about but I know if I get into the weeds
with it so I would love to
there's maybe even things you could
schedule where we're all on Zoom
together where you can hear my heart and
hear my vision
because I would not want to fully
abdicate it's be totally practical to
have a manager that works with the VA
and they never know who the VA is but I
just think from a leadership standpoint
yes all of that's true but your your job
is to cast The Vision And if you're
gonna build a strong team even if it's
just a few remote people that are
contract workers
like think thinking like a leader
casting Vision
um having that care and empathy that's
also the best way to retain people is is
not even a tactic it's like gen you know
genuinely care but then also and then
and then having that transparency
because also people want to be needed
and so not being afraid and that's
essentially what you're saying same
thing I'm saying I just told my team
today too I said listen
we have to start Building Systems we
have to have I said where is the written
list where is it documented how could it
be handed on to somebody else now here's
the thing
what you know you all need to realize
Brian Trey uh Tyler uh here's what I'm
aware of
I I'm not good at this
I'm good at this I can tell you all 62
steps in my head right now because I
built the whole thing with it only up
here
that's why I hired you this is a huge
weakness weakness for me guys I need you
to capture Drea uh who's in our think
media administ I need you to like be
looking at all these these pieces in
these systems and then these need to be
documented they need to be written
because I I actually do suck at this and
we need to get it from my mind and not
just my mind Kyle's mind and we need to
have it put into a place so that's it
just a little Nuance on and does that
make sense as far as I think building
culture a little bit because you're
gonna I you're really on the ground
floor of building a legit media company
here and I have a few more thoughts but
uh any any pushback on that
no no it's absolutely great that's
that's been the struggle I've taken some
missteps I try bringing a full-time
intern but then it was kind of actively
managing them became kind of more work
and uh I I that surprised me I was like
I'm just supposed to hire people right
and then like you said it's like oh I
have to become something I have to
become a manager I have to become a
leader and uh not just motivating myself
but motivating the team and and there's
so much that goes into that and uh you
know we just naturally just go well if
I'm good at this I'll be good at
managing a company that does this and
that's not true at all we need to be
reading those books and and getting more
and that's one of the things I really
appreciate about you and VRA and
everything like that is that you are one
of the few channels that really kind of
starts talking about that that
leadership uh transfer and that building
a team not just uh getting more views
I appreciate that and uh where you are
is and a really tough spot actually like
you're getting into higher levels of
complexity but it's also a higher level
of fun and uh I think you're gonna do
great the the the next thing
and we can land the plane here and then
any final question you have because I
talked about two questions and question
one was how can I buy back my time
question one was even if you also do
manage uh just to land the plane there
on that previous point the Leadership
Lessons I've learned is delegate but
don't dump
uh you have to inspect what you expect
and when we are
feeling already a little bit overwhelmed
that's also it's it's an impossible
Place almost to manage or lead from
so that's why if you can find the
delegatable things like
maybe none of these things are true but
there was I was thinking about um
like changing your own oil like I was
talking to my neighbor about changing
Not only would I not know how to do it
but but he was like yeah you know I
saved money and he enjoys doing it and
he's got a great job he does in the
medical field and so he actually like
it's therapeutic to work on his car but
I actually have to start auditing my
time being like it acts it is an
irresponsible use of my time to change
my own oil it is what is an ear it's an
irresponsible use of my time to fill in
the blank
because if anything if it just gives me
back sanity or it buys back time for if
you're gonna transfer culture DNA how
you like it done you've got to be
present so it's not just delegate it's
it's delegate but it's not just dump and
it's not just you have to inspect what
you expect which is why even though my
the wrong mentality I could have is like
I'm the CEO I'm the founder now
um you should just get it you should
just do it and you all need to build it
sometimes my team could maybe think
opposite of this people say like don't
don't micromanage I'm like no you should
micromanage you actually should
micromanage until
you have transferred the nuances and
details that you care about in the
company that you want to build
so I've got this written right here 150
a day
150 a day I learned this at the Vault
conference petrobat David will gudera
from unreasonable Hospitality book we
should link that one up in the show
notes as well killer book for leadership
he's from
um the restaurant in New York fifth
Madison uh or whatever it's called
number one restaurant in the world five
Michelin star
they built this world-class culture 150
a day is what leaders and managers
should do in terms of how many
compliments and criticisms they give a
day and criticisms are important you
want to create a culture where people
are desensitized to criticism meaning
it's not like you you criticize them but
they don't go oh my gosh that hurt my
feelings oh like you told me to change
the font oh why were you so mean like no
like it's just normal that you're like
no actually this is how I want the video
optimized this is how I want the
chapters done this is how I want the
font I know actually this is how I want
the description done I I need a system I
need it written I need it in monday.com
I need it accessible I need the link to
work and so you've back to buying back
your time you don't want to do this but
this actually is your job if you're
going to start building a team and if
you're going to train a manager to think
this way now it's not just criticism in
fact probably a hundred compliments and
50 criticism every day now you don't
have a huge team or or to do that yet
but that's that's a big number and we
use slack so I think about uh hey Steph
incredible Hook you know hey Nate really
good title you're like really cool the
way you think about this you know hey
Drea thanks for catching that
um and thinking about whatever your
value values are whatever your culture
is whatever the things that you love in
your YouTube channel what you're
building You Want To Praise what you the
behavior you want people to repeat so
you want to even acknowledge like oh
dang that video is a banger that thing
was whatever like that was really good
because people need encouragement
anyways but you especially want to
encourage uh when someone does things
right sometimes we are silent when
things would when people do things right
let me know if you're watching this uh
we only speak up if something's wrong
because if it's right you just don't
hear from us whereas we want to be that
much more active and let me know if your
bosses do this coffee with candle do you
have a good culture where you work does
your boss criticize and and I mean like
constructive criticism do you get enough
feedback at work do you get too much
negative feedback do you get too much
positive feedback and so you want to
have a lot of encouragement sometimes
they talk about the the sandwich the
Oreo of of like encouragement here's a
few tweaks you could do to improve
that's in the middle and then some
encouragement at the end
um and that level of feedback is how you
transfer your standards it's how you
transfer what Excellence is it's how you
transfer what Mastery is and too many
leaders want to just dump not delegate
but just dump and be like hey I hope
that and then they wonder why
people don't know how you think and if
you've only said it once they didn't
catch it you probably need to repeat it
seven times and uh yeah people don't
people don't realize how dialed in you
have to to get to the level I'm at
everything has to be dialed in there's a
reason for everything there's a reason
for that font there's a reason for that
color background there's a reason for
that tint there's a reason for
everything and uh people people are
beginning their YouTube Journey that's
what you need to do experiment and and
dial everything in
and then then it gets hard to transfer
it like what you're saying
yeah so we've covered that at length
final thought for you
um is once your time is bought back the
thing I think that's interesting for you
is the creation of video essays
so video essays and we talk about some
of this stuff in um
in VRA Masters now which are already
super busy already applying things
but there's like 20 new hours of content
in the VRA master so that's a lot so you
chip away at that on your commutes or
you don't have a commute but on your
drives to the store or whatever
um speaking of storage just one other
thing even down like do you do you order
groceries or do you have your food
automated at all so every week I do a
video of me going to the store okay
so it's optimized that way nice
um and stuff so um
video essays kind of could be considered
they're a little bit of like the
skyscraper method
they're a little bit of of kind of like
long form high value
um two people I could think you could be
learning from I think right now
um
Patrick David is
uh doing these
kind of
deep dive
polarizing
g20's hidden agenda
um
Argentina's economic catastrophe the
Panama Canal Crisis how it impacts the
world com economy
Water Crisis NATO exposed a million
views I don't know if um and then one of
the ones he did China's apocalypse 1.7
mu uh million views one of the ones he
did was
on um
the Carl Schwab World economic economic
forum
uh warning Carl Schwab and the world
economic Forum want to control your life
844 000 views
and he's hired multiple researchers now
and those those have
um helped him
uh scale and yes he's already these are
already things he's passionate about but
he has somebody like help him build a
deck help him get all this information
he then may take three four hours the
night before recording and just like
figure out his own notes and get clear
on the data but all this deck is built
by somebody else
so I guess the vision that I have for
you and then one other to Define what a
video essay is so these are kind of like
that sort of and but that's still
getting 120 views an hour the Carl
Schwab ones four weeks old
um
they're almost maybe like mini
documentaries in a way of like a video
essay there maybe you'd have b-roll on
them they're getting or they would for
sure they might they'd have b-roll
they'd have something more to them and
they're they're like more of an
evergreen type of a story that could
very well be related to news
the pushback I would imagine is you go
man to sustain the content flow I'm
already on it'd be very hard to create
that but what I would be asking is okay
so how can I question number one buy
back my time optimize what I'm doing
maybe even staff up ahead of time this
is what we're doing at think media we
are investing dollars right now and
scaling the team that have not directly
made us more money
so we are reinvesting profits and
scaling the business because we're
getting we're planting seeds today for
the Harvest that we want to reap
tomorrow with faith and practicality
that
the seeds we plant today are preparing
us to be able to sustain the level of
output the level of Excellence the level
of strategy as well as me in general I'm
all I'm constantly thinking about how
can I buy back my time my greatest place
maybe it's not my greatest place but my
greatest function similar to yours
I would argue not only in passion but
also in
maybe skill passion for sure skill set
maybe is actually being a content
creator and I've never been less of a
content creator than I am today
I must I don't want to be a CEO
I I want to be a content creator I don't
I don't I will do it I'll do whatever it
takes I am choosing to enjoy it because
I enjoy every I worked at Red Robin for
10 years I chose to enjoy it every
single day it was fun it was fun talking
to people so my perspective is positive
but I'm just trying to chart a path to
say how could I buy back my time
um we already we have a CEO in training
I think that she's one two three four
five years out so me actually may be
hitting the Target that I'm after is
five years from now and maybe it'll be
two and a half based on the activities
we take and maybe other things so
um ultimately and in doing so I've got
lists of videos Banger videos different
things but I also am embracing the
season to say whether that's one of the
things we're going to be doing is
recruiting Talent if anybody's
interested on the replayer live where we
also want to onboard other content
creators
um specifically with like expertise
around say a social media platform or
YouTube ads or cameras or Tech or maybe
video editing computers or something
like the core things that we teach kind
of like an Omar and Nolan
um and if you're interested you know
we're not doing auditions yet but if if
you're watching this that's something
that's in the works so there's different
things we're building according to the
season
um and then furthermore I have put out
there working with Melissa on our team
do we need a researcher because I've
realized I can go faster if I had a
researcher in our podcast and video
interviews or could right now uh there's
looks like a new PA coming on personal
assistant shifting one around could she
wear multiple hats so it's all it's this
is bit this is entrepreneurship this is
business this is entrepreneurship but
for you to do a a 35 minute deep dive
polished more polished video essay
something on the topics that you cover
maybe you can't do that this month and
maybe you can't do that next month
because I I the smarter thing for you to
do you already felt it is like this is
what pays the bills
but these are the kind of questions I
would be thinking about is how am I
navigating towards that in terms of how
I'm what am I willing to sacrifice keep
expenses low personal life expense is
low because if I onboard somebody today
I may need to pay them for six months
without much Roi that's that's the
trouble is it gotta gotta you can't tell
somebody well I might fire you next
month if you're getting someone full
time they need to you need to be able to
guarantee you six months or a year
salary
and if I get kicked off YouTube next
week or something like that that's out
of my control and so yeah and I mean
true and you should take that personal
responsibility but you only have to ever
pay them every two weeks and so
you can't guarantee them nor are you
obligated to pay them for a year if you
go out of business you would stop you
would you would lay them off I know it's
a very serious issue but just one
thought is if you were to even pay
somebody
you know you only ever have to pay
somebody every two weeks
um you don't have when someone goes man
I can't upport I can't afford 50 000
salary well you don't have to pay fifty
thousand dollars right now you just have
to pay for two weeks
attention to manage so the mindset is
and and in hiring somebody I also
if I'm in your shoes I'm not hiring W-2s
you're in a very Scrappy season where I
would work personally you do whatever
you want of course look at labor laws
whatever but like working with
contractors keeping it lean and that's
how you cast Vision too you cast Vision
along the lines of Hey listen
we're in a really cool spot like money's
coming in views are coming in uh but
it's tight and I think the future is
really bright but if you're looking for
like an established proven 10 years of
History uh Healthcare job this is not
the place for you the Poplar report is
not the place for you but if you are
looking to get on the ground floor keep
your main job work an extra 10 or 20
hours a week
um do some contract work for me uh even
at like kind of low pay that could scale
as results happen like because you don't
have to leave your main thing to do this
I would be much that's the season you're
in it's much more like kind of growth
hacking like that
um we are now hiring like W-2s and still
I mean again I want there to be enough
trust and stability so people are like
holy crap is think media going out of
business like we just hired like Logan
and Keith were on our meeting today and
they're like watching coffee Channel
are we Sean only got two weeks of you
know uh but but ultimately yeah we're
like we want we're very conservative
with our cash reserves and we think
about what is sustainability and we now
are much more healthcare for US starts
January 1st we do have W-2 employees
some contractors but we're seven years
the background is uh accounting so I'm
thinking all along those lines yep
um so really cool conversation so
anyways I by the way long story short
those video essays or maybe like search
based
um when I think about video essays
um
Patrick cc is kind of an example
uh it's a little bit different or it's
way different than your Niche but if you
look at how good is so he does stuff
like let's see Disney is perfectly happy
with her downfall the most hated d-list
celebrity in Hollywood so he really Taps
into influence surfing you can kind of
see the style and if you look at Patrick
Cece's videos in terms of how he
narrates them there's like a script
there but what's Wild is if we go to
like most popular this is a year old and
still getting 92 views an hour Bam
Margera Rob Dyrdek 64 views an hour
inside is photos
um clips of shows kind of a fair use
play a very good story he barely is on
camera
but he's on there a couple times and he
navigates he narrates through
um you know his his content uh different
clips of shows and it's and that's just
what I mean by a video essay 5 million
views very lucrative
and you get a couple of these on your
channel and perhaps you could get to a
baseline of Revenue that
gives you some margin and some peace of
mind and you you create those when
you're inspired and you create those
when you've got a team maybe you got
even very part-time contractor somebody
kind of helps you with initial research
they maybe help you with the script you
finish off the script you deliver it you
kick it to a video editor you review the
edit you're not in a rush to put it out
you put out the video and it's kind of
more of like a piece of more premium
media with the attempt of something you
care about something related to your
mission something related to the news
all that stuff
um but that is
uh has a much longer shelf life does
that make sense yeah absolutely
Steve any final question I uh can answer
for you on this uh conversation today
you just dumped a fire load a fire host
load on me just like you did Keith I got
so many notes here and I'm gonna have to
re-watch this and uh take all it for a
second and spin awesome well I
appreciate you Steve love what you're
doing and thanks so much for being a
part of our community
thanks so much
my friends
um when we titled today's episode of the
coffee with camel show
YouTube and Creator business advice I
didn't know that we were actually going
to take it there so this was that was a
fun uh conversation related to Creator
business advice scaling a team
leadership all the nuances of that kind
of stuff
um and uh I would love to know your aha
moment I'm gonna answer a couple
questions here that have come in text
you can always put question marks before
and after the question and uh we're
gonna check that out in just a second
but I'm gonna take a sip of coffee and
check this out are you ready to start or
grow your YouTube channel do you feel
stuck and need help connecting the dots
join this free web class where you'll
learn the step-by-step playbook for
YouTube success we've helped thousands
of purpose-driven entrepreneurs just
like you grow their influence with video
register today for this exclusive
training at thinkmasterclass.com
welcome back to the coffee with candle
show my name is Sean Cannell I'm looking
up a more what's a more positive word
for criticism
um
I think that uh we were talking about
150 a day
150 a day is how many if you're a leader
if you're a manager
um
and I'm over here in chat GPT
constructive feedback input advice
suggestions insights comments
observations and recommendations
so
I I see you Akin media I definitely get
it I know that
I like that you say it comes with I
don't like the word criticize uh
evaluation growth points now what I
would challenge you though the reason I
like the word criticize
is because I sometimes think
that we can be too soft most people go
to the extreme some of us maybe have
trauma because we were criticized by a
parent or criticized by a really harmful
boss I actually think I've leaned
probably to the more two soft side
nobody on the think team agrees but
that's where I think Eileen and I and I
uh maybe have avoided difficult
conversations or or you know
constructive quote-unquote criticism but
here is a big key in the 150 goal
you actually want to desensitize people
to criticism you want it to be that
number here's the Anchor Point number
one they know you love them number two
they know that you and this is the
missing piece of probably most people
that have traumatized you with criticism
number one you know that they they they
truly love you care about your best
interest wants what's best for you and
want what's best for the collective your
entire family they want what's best for
the whole um Team the whole business
and then number three that in that
context when you're criticized when they
because I get you we could we could try
to sugarcoat it by well it's just
feedback but critique
is is how we get better you know even
biblically it says let a righteous man
strike me it's like oil upon my head
which biblically is like the anointing
like I actually get stronger and my
gifts my my gifts callings and abilities
when I am struck let a righteous man
strike me as Oppo oh let him just like
kind of kindly and I know like there's a
balance to it all it's attention but
it's like no struck is hurt are you
familiar with the Bible verse let iron
sharpen iron
so so one friend sharpens another as
iron sharpens iron have you ever
pictured that
if you take iron
and put it against iron is that like all
butterflies and rainbows and unicorns no
that's Sparks that's grinding I think a
key word it might hurt like it kind of
can hurt
but the reason we're trying to
desensitize people to criticism and
think is is that one one they get
encouraged more than they get feedback
two they know they're loved three they
understand our core value is it's the
pursuit of Mastery so a lot of times
I'll frame up the conversation like this
I'll be like listen number one we just
won the game y'all number two we're in
the locker room number three I want you
all to know we just won like you did an
incredible job number four let's be like
Kobe
and let's review the game tape what
could we have done better and it might
be even better rather than like jumping
in on somebody it becomes language
within your Excellence Culture Your
Mastery culture where people go you know
yeah I know we won but I kind of dropped
the ball there you know it was a mistake
that I made oh yeah like I should have
caught that and even too where this is
this should not be bossed down
this should be 360 Degrees all around it
actually you look at the book radical
Candor you look at the book
um radical uh
uh
radical can there's another one
that'll look up and so it's being
candorous and being okay that we call
out each other's peers like hey uh you
know Kyle could say hey Nolan you know
you did drop the ball here
I need you to uh that that's not okay
but that that's not like oh my gosh how
dare you give me feedback that
everyone's just like this is how we talk
to each other because we're on the same
Mission we all know we love each other
not that it's always easy but it gets
uncomfortable because iron scraping
against iron
um and of course we praise in public we
criticize typically privately unless
it's not like a huge deal so if you go
one to one hey uh great job you know but
a couple things here and uh
uh I'm curious I would love your
feedback because this is a conversation
here on the coffee with candle show
um but but I I know personal if anything
this is my personal growth Journey
I'm actually trying to be better at it
so I respect I love that you brought it
up constructive feedback giving somebody
some input giving somebody a little bit
of advice
giving people some suggestions by the
way this criticism is not a suggestion
like especially if it is the boss like
I'm not just making a suggestion here
this is actually the standard uh that we
need you to rise to here's some insights
here's some comments here's some
recommendations the word the choice of
the world largely depends on the context
and the tone you wish to convey if
you're aiming for positive and
constructive tone feedback and
constructive feedback is a good choice
so I agree tone is huge
um but uh ultimately our goal
is uh radical acceptance
our goal is to we're there's this good
book called the advantage too that we're
reading as team directors and uh we are
um
uh radical Candor here's here's the book
how to be a kick butt boss without
losing your Humanity
um and that's one for leaders to check
out and there's a in the advantage as
well they talk about you need to have
trust on the leadership team and you
need to be able to just like call things
out exactly how they are not have any
weird avoiding hard conversations things
and hold each other accountable for each
other's performance
this is tough stuff man makes a lot of
other people uncomfortable
um okay so what do you all think yeah
lancioni the advantage really good one
uh positive reinforcement of course
here's some questions
um
yeah and and let's land the plane here
perhaps the problem with many leaders is
they criticize and they don't give
compliments a hundred percent
so I think if you got 150 times a day on
your teams
um whoever by the way in your family
likes parents are afraid to like
critique your kids now again real toxic
stuff is like a mom critiquing the way
the daughter looks or something like
that gets all weird and I know we all
have trauma with that stuff but it's
like
like the like children need guidance and
little adjustments and continuous
adjustments that it just becomes normal
culture that you're the parent you're
giving guidance
um but man if all and that would
probably be one of my other mistakes you
would only hear from me if you did
something wrong because if you did
something right then just silent I'm
trying to increase
we use slack so do a post in slack hey
great job verbally in every meeting
constant encouragement Bible by the way
says encourage one another daily why
it's called today literally encourage
one another daily so a hundred positive
encouraging statements things said a
spoonful of sugar helps the medicine go
down and then but also but here's
something we need to address here's a
little bit of feedback there's a good
reminder that there's someone you love
in your life while you're watching the
coffee with candle show fireman off a
text seriously
if you're if your marriage is very few
and far between with positive
encouragement your spouse is going to be
shocked that just in the middle of the
day you're just like hey I just want to
send you a text I love you I appreciate
you you're sexy and I'm so grateful for
everything you do for our family
send that text right now let me know
what happens if they respond over the
next few minutes while we land the plane
on these questions okay here we go Lisa
I have three topics I'm passionate how
do I choose between them at some point
you just gotta choose
uh but the best thing you could do is go
to uh findyourtopic.com
and we have a class that is all about
how to find the best channel topic that
gets views and earns money for you
that's
findyourtopic.com that is exactly for
sake of time Lisa only about I think a
30 minute training that by the end of
that class you'll know which of the
three topics uh that'll be best for your
channel Ahmad says is it good to
practice
to use AI to create video scripts if yes
what do you choose
I think that video scripts are great
um and I think using AI can help you go
a lot faster our sponsor of today's
coffee with candle is vid IQ and you can
get a 30 day trial of it iq's boost plan
for just a dollar vidiq.com forward
slash think I think what's um powerful
about vid IQ is they do have an AI coach
and you could say
I mean first of all here's what's Wild
is it's tied into my channel so see how
I've got Advanced here because of the
Boost plan that I'm on
and it's got the diamond that means it
actually analyzes my channel think media
and I actually have it connected to my
think media podcast Channel as well
um so I can actually know that I'm at
the channel then it says based on my
channel what video ideas do you have for
me so it's kind of cool so it just the
prompts are just started for me so it's
like what video ideas do you have for me
based on think media which focuses on
tech reviews cameras tutorials and
YouTube growth the future of tech
predictions for 2024
um kind of cool look at it it actually
is giving me not a script but an outline
it's giving me the thumbnail idea around
10 to 15 minutes target audience Tech
enthusiasts description dive into
upcoming Tech Trends and make
predictions about what's going to be big
in 2024 this could include new Gadget
software Tech related practices
mastering YouTube top five growth
strategies for 2024. it's a little early
to hit 2024 but those are definitely
good for the queue
camera Showdown oh it's beautiful so
then uh behind the scenes of think media
day of the life uh Tech unboxing
and remember these are just ideas so
let's look at
the future of tech predictions for 2024
can you write a short script for this
video
let me see what it comes up with here
what I love about about AI is
it
can get you so it can get you a head
start
but man AI is not there yet in terms of
if you will doing it all for you like if
you just like a robot read the whole
script I just think you need your human
touch on it but if you look at like how
far this is coming up main content and
it even tells you some clips to include
first up I predict that Ai and then it's
talking about
um virtual reality VR and boom I would
move this to a Google doc
space it out a little bit and then fill
some things in even just the sheer
amount of like how much I could start
editing
it offloaded so much heavy lifting on my
brain so that would be a tool I would
recommend and if you want to check that
out there's a free version too you can
um get of of not just
their AI coach but a vid IQ but if you
want to get a 30-day trial of it iq's
boost plan for just a dollar you could
go to vidiq.com forward slash think or
check out the uh Link in the description
thank you Mimi for the Super Chat really
appreciate you and thanks so much for
being here today
how do we balance
content Creation in university studies
Sophie asks
so I think when it comes to balancing
YouTube content creation and anything
whether it's university studies whether
it's parenting whether it's
a 40-hour week job with a one hour two
hour commute I think the first step is
to do a Time audit
where actually is your time going
the second step is to identify any
things you can cut out of your calendar
the third step because now you've got
some time back and now if you if you
could say Sophie
okay I identified five hours a week I
identified 10 hours a week if I'm
aggressive I identified 15 hours a week
and then of course you're being
realistic you probably need a little bit
more sleep as a student you might need
some more but so you go I got 15 hours a
week but practically 10 is probably for
sure it's nice to have a little bit of
margin I'm never gonna be perfect with
it great I found 10 hours a week that's
significant we're about to drop a video
about what I would do on YouTube If I
Only Had 10 hours a week and two
thousand dollars to start as a budget
and
I would then number three write down
your values and your priorities
I will admit Sophie that it could be
possible that it's not a season that you
can really do YouTube I mean I think
anybody could do YouTube shorts and
upload here or there and be as
consistent as possible but you might
literally say you're like Sean I'm
taking 18 credits
I also am already a parent and I have
six kids I also work two jobs
and how do I do YouTube as well and I
would tell you uh you don't I mean what
you're actually what we actually
probably need to figure out how to like
reduce your job I don't know you got the
kids you got the two jobs you've got 18
credits at the University I don't even
know how you're alive so so like
sometimes I think we could be
impractical with our schedule on the
flip side once we start finding what's
on our schedule we backfill that's what
I would say values and priorities like
when I was working at a church YouTube
was my priority
it's why I learned how to rank videos
but there were certain Seasons Easter
month sometimes the holidays or whatever
where I didn't upload for a month but
then there was also Seasons when it
slowed down so my consistency also just
looked like I was really consistent
during the slower summer and and on a
year I made forward progress but certain
Seasons something had to give so when
you know what your values and priorities
are in list you're like okay number one
I can't let my university studies drop
number two I can't you know let my kids
or my family or this responsibility drop
number you know and then you're like all
right
but then is your priority gaming or
watching Netflix or something else and
if you've got something like YouTube a
side Hustle
then that's what's going to get plugged
into that 10 hour gap that you freed up
and then you guard that thing diligently
and you're like what I can't do
I'm gonna nurture a couple friendships
but I'm just not gonna go out Friday
night Saturday I'm going to sleep
recover and I'm gonna Crush my side
hustle on Saturday why everybody else is
partying I'm gonna be building my future
and focusing on my purpose and my
priorities
so then that becomes up to you and and
figuring all of that out and then here's
your radical tip
I'm not suggesting this I was throwing
it out there this isn't directed to
Sophie it's directed to everybody
what if you just drop out of University
I mean I'm not suggesting that that's
the move
but sometimes
we are so we're trying to fit a square
peg and a round hole
when
it's at least for the thought exercise
worth questioning the whole thing
not being irrational and crazy but
someone's like
well Sean I'm just in an area where I
can't grow my YouTube channel because
I'm in a small town and I'm not like
where all the action is
well the cool thing about YouTube is you
don't need to you can do it from
anywhere
but here's the radical thought move
I mean just for the thought exercise
well my current job and my current boss
like they're just holding me back and
like I just then quit
well like I mean I just don't think I
could do YouTube because I mean if I
look at all the priorities and all the
things that I'm doing on my schedule and
I've got I hang out with my friend Lisa
every week and we do this kind of thing
and then I hang out with Rebecca well do
you really even like Lisa and Rebecca
think about it
relax they're like holy this is a weird
coffee with candle I'm just saying I'm
just saying like it's you could take a
step back because if you're really
auditing our year is your calendar
aligned with your highest values with
your future why are you going to
University are you going to University
because it's related to the career that
for sure you're going to do and that's
the stability are you going because your
parents told you to go and you're are
you going because you just like hate not
finishing things so you're going to
finish it and rack up more debt I'm not
trying to get into your business Sophie
I'm trying to talk to all of us to say
sometimes it's smart to question
how could I look at this from a whole
different Vantage Point could I reduce
my monthlies what do you spend audit the
final tip audit your calendar and audit
your credit card I was just talking to
my friend Benji about this
I said man you want to know what
somebody's values are you don't have to
talk to them if you could if you could
look at two things look at their
calendar for the last 90 days and look
at their credit card or your debit card
for you Dave Ramsey fans and look at
where did your money go and where did
your time go and if we look at your
credit card and we're like okay so it
went to a drake ticket Taylor Swift
ticket it went into a Mariners game it
went to hundreds of dollars on alcohol
and uh hot dogs out of Mariners game it
went to all this you know whatever it
went to golf it went to some other
things and then my calendar went to this
job that I don't really like but I just
tolerated it because I just don't want
to and then we edit the whole thing and
you go Sean I just don't have time for
my dreams
well if you reduced spending on the
Drake tickets the Taylor Swift tickets
the the overpriced beer at the sports
game and the other things that would
allow you to maybe go part-time at your
job or get a different job thereby
buying you some time back thereby
allowing you to work on your side hustle
for a little bit longer
but that's entirely up to you because
what are your values what are your
priorities and don't it's not what you
tell me your values and priorities are
it's what your calendar tells me your
values and priorities are because that's
actually how you're spending your time
and it's what your checkbook tells me
well Sean I always got to get a new
outfit and I always gotta order Uber
Eats and I always have to get my coffee
and I always have to and I'm a big
encouragement of that stuff I'm never
like the path to become a millionaire is
not going to Starbucks that's like
actually not what I believe but I think
the path to becoming a millionaire is
making more money and investing it
smarter and producing more not really
thinking about constriction but thinking
about abundance and thinking about
expansion but you know drink your coffee
so you can come home and edit for longer
you know I think like how do I get
entrepreneurial while enjoying my
ubereats and my coffee however it is
smart in some Seasons to be like dear
God I could literally recover a thousand
dollars a month because I'm being so I'm
such a poor Steward of my financial
resources and in doing so I would
actually be able to now reach faster
towards my YouTube dreams so
you could take a radical move drop out
quit move relocate drop the energy
vampire friends drop the time you think
you have to go uh I'm not trying to
disrupt your business but you go in and
playing golf for four five six hours not
only the expense but the guys that
you're hanging out with and I don't know
if iron really sharpened iron there but
by the time it was all gossip by the
time it was all about like just
complaining about your spouse by the
time it was guys just complaining about
their job and not masterminding and
brainstorming about how to be creative
and industrious and how to be positive
and how to take territory and how to
move things man just staying home saving
money and working on your side hustle
arms and personal development Compound
Effect multiplied by three six nine
twelve months five years ten years puts
you in a whole different place by making
that radical shift to your checkbook or
to your calendar
smash like if you're uh happy for coffee
with candle today and uh that was a good
question Sophie I appreciate you
I hedge a little too much because I
again of course I'm not trying to be in
your business at all but you ask the
question and I do hope that that added
value and maybe uh it it caused you to
think different different than just
small tweaks sometimes it's about a
radical shift
any feedback on that one
amen TVR creators I appreciate you busy
with dogs Sophie I appreciate you uh the
Poplar report appreciate you
um all right a couple more that we will
land the plane smart goals what are
smart goals
smart goals for everybody if you've
never heard about them before
setting smart goals can be powerful
specific measurable achievable relevant
and time-bound
if you want to set goals that are strong
that are actually powerful are they
specific are they measurable how do you
know you've reached it are they actually
achievable not like I'm going to start
benching a thousand pounds in the next
10 days not actually achievable for me
is it actually relevant to your
priorities your values and is it
time-bound I'm going to do it in the
next 30 days next 60 days next 90 days
one video a week for the next
year 52 videos a year that goal is an
output goal is an upload on YouTube I'm
going to find a way to reach that goal
time bound really really good
I would say though I heard somebody say
smart goals are dumb
and let me tell you about dream goals
uh you ever heard of dream goals
and so let me see if I can find these
for you and
um
so dream goals
let me see
uh I'm gonna use harpa AI to to find
this really quick
that's a cool one to summarize YouTube
videos
um all right I'm gonna tell you about
dream goals in just a second let me hit
another question smart goals are good
dream goals might be better all right
busy with dogs do you think mini Vlogs
via shorts have longevity my shorts are
starting
like that are starting to have thousands
of views
I I think that I would check out
um if intermittent fasting with Ryan if
you search if Ryan
uh
that's kinda I would just I would just
study that it's probably different than
everybody thanks for watching kind of
his main content format
um
full day of eating steak for lunch full
day of eating I mean 91 000 87 000 and
he is vlogging so he's like the way he
story tells and does a day the way he
edits
he they're they're short they're
obviously less than 60 seconds and
they're crushing I mean his channel uh
we have a think media podcast 4.6
million views a month we have a think
media podcast with him he breaks down
how he's built this into like a 12 000 a
month plus business
so
um
if we can find that podcast we'll link
it up with Ryan Johnson
and you could check out his channel Ryan
underscore Johnson at Ryan underscore
Johnson intermittent fasting with Ryan
and I do think that many Vlogs via
shorts
um could be something that's really
powerful
um
okay
uh
I'm looking for these
these uh smart
the dumb goals details so I get all the
letters right for you
um
oh
uh
let me see
okay you ready
never done this on a slow never slow
down this much
so
we'll cover that in a second okay
the weirdest lull of Silence on the
gobby channel hey uh great to have you
live after a Facebook have a question
how can I make a dead Channel active
with 12 000 subscribers uh farhand for
time's sake subscribe to the think media
podcast Channel thanks so much for
watching coffee with Channel over on
Facebook uh we just did a podcast with
um orderly the DIY designer and we broke
down 30 minutes on this exact topic and
so otherwise you know just for time's
sake I would encourage you hopefully
you're already listening but if you
didn't know we have a podcast and so
um in fact check this out did you know
that we have a weekly show called The
think media podcast if you want to learn
the best strategies for growing your
business and brand with YouTube for how
to thrive as a Creator or how to get
more leads and clients and customers as
an entrepreneur and I want to invite you
to subscribe to the think media podcast
available on YouTube and all of the
audio platforms on this show you're
gonna find Advanced strategies for
understanding YouTube for building the
business mechanics around your YouTube
channel including your email list or
taking what you know and turning it into
profitable products we have amazing
guest interviews and all kinds of
special surprises that happen
consistently on the think media podcast
so to get access for free just click the
link in the description or go to
youtube.com forward slash think media
podcast
foreign
I am ready I looked this up I found this
from Brandon burchard and so smart goals
of course are very popular but let me
land the plane today with dumb goals
everyone's out here trying to set smart
goals when in fact it might be smarter
to set dumb goals what does dumb stand
for number one dream driven
dumb goals are dream driven so sometimes
I think with goal setting we're so
practical
like it's too incremental it's too it's
too small like so so dumb goals are like
what if we have a big hairy audacious
goal what if we actually shop for for
the Stars what if we actually dreamed
big dream driven goals not just smart
practical trying to lose five pounds
what could be a very aspirational goal
because that could really get us
inspired number two the you in Dumb
goals is uplifting and so they're
positive inspiring positive joyous
uplifting goals number three method
friendly and so if you're going to aim
at something aim at something that has
practices to it and so if you can have
again if our goal is like I just kind of
have like more happiness in my marriage
good but like what's the method like is
there actually something like I want to
actually establish a consistent time of
date nights in my marriage there's
actually a method to that and here's
what we're gonna do with those
those date nights powerful thing about
that the dream is I just want a more
powerful marriage the Practical is that
there's actually a method to it and then
number four the b in Dumb goals is
behavior triggered
um you want to have a behavioral trigger
that makes you think about doing it my
friend Spencer told me to start doing
push-ups because I have man boobs I'm
turning 40 this year okay you can
imagine
um and he's like I started doing
um 50 push-ups every single day no
matter what and he said what I did was I
created a trigger which was as soon as I
walk over the threshold into my bathroom
the threshold every time I walk through
this doorway the trigger is drop and do
50. and he's like and that's just what I
always do like that's the trigger like
what is the trigger
um like if you want to be a better
parent then you set up a behavior
trigger to accomplish it so that when
you pull into the driveway at night
that's the thing that happens a thought
is to take a moment and Center yourself
to find a calm loving space before
entering the house I heard that from a
mentor once they realize all the stress
from work all the wound up stuff all the
different battles and fires that they
had they're about to carry those home
um and you usually carry those home and
you didn't even mean to and so the
practice was pull into the driveway as
you park take a beat and if your person
of faith maybe God I pray that all the
stress of the day would melt away I pray
that you actually shift my focus that I
could go in in inside my home with
intent to love and encourage my wife to
be present for my kids and just being a
state of calm and peace and I just leave
all the open loops and all the unsolved
problems and all the different
relational tension I just give that all
to you get into a state and then head
inside now that's going to be a behavior
trigger that is going to help you maybe
reach the dream driven goal of building
a stronger family so I like them both
they're smart goals
specific measurable something
relatable time and then there's dumb
goals dream driven uplifting method
friendly Behavior triggered which one do
you like better you ever heard of the
dumb goals before let me know and uh
with that my friends we're at an hour
and 56 minutes
it's closing time here at the coffee
with camel show but I'm curious if you
have an aha moment from today and I mean
it I mean I I does I love seeing your
comments I love seeing you engage in the
chat I love seeing you in the comments
if you're on replay fam hashtag replay
fam now I know you're a real one an hour
and 56 minutes into the replay of this
show that's incredible we had some good
conversations high level leadership
combos today
so let me know what stood out but the
power of the aha moment is what we
articulate what we socialize by putting
it out there in public this was the
unlock this is my action item where
hashtag action takers and the VRA fam
and the coffee with candle family and so
um if we drop in the chat the AHA the
unlock but also what's the action what
are you gonna do next what are you going
to implement we're on a mission to help
one million purpose-driven people create
a full-time living while doing what they
love and making a difference in the
world with YouTube helping you do what
you love and make a difference in the
world with YouTube and so that's what
this show is all about you could
subscribe here on YouTube you can listen
to the think media podcast which comes
out on all the audio platforms and on
the same channel two times a week every
once in a while there's a bonus episode
as well and uh so many cool things that
we have planned but uh thank you so much
for being a part of the show today he
reminds me of sami's song dum-dum uh
yeah stem goals for the win Sophie's
about to get to editing and I love that
appreciate you busy dogs uh I heard you
talk about what you really value and how
you spend your time is a great reminder
uh appreciate you thanks so much for uh
your feedback of being a part of the
show today Poplar report thanks for the
convo love what you're doing it's
awesome to hear that story too Poplar is
full time man and now now it's my money
more problems like he's out here in the
words of uh the great prophet and
theologian The Notorious Big Mo Money Mo
Problems you know it's like ultimately
that once you go full time we're here
for you not just to help you get there
to go part-time or full-time during
YouTube but as soon as you get there now
you're like this is pretty cool and I
got other challenges and so we're just
trying to share all the answers possible
through all of our videos live streams
courses events all of that stuff helping
you crush on YouTube build a profitable
Channel and do it in a way that you
don't lose your soul but you can really
uh make an impact and stay healthy in
the process my name is Sean Cannell
rhymes with YouTube channel I will see
you in a future episode of the coffee
with Channel show